- [Interviewer] You're going
to be guessing which foods
have had microplastics discovered in them.
- God damn it.
- Oh so, little bits of plastic.
Okay.
- Am I gonna die from doing this?
- Define microplastics.
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] So,
microplastics are plastics
that are smaller than the
size of a grain of rice.
These tiny pieces of plastic
then trickle down into our ecosystem.
And, the thing with plastic is,
it doesn't go away, it just breaks down
into smaller and smaller pieces.
- Yikes.
- Is microplastics dangerous in food?
- [Interviewer] We don't
know the ramifications yet.
- It can't be good, right?
That's the moral of this.
You can't just go eat a bunch of Legos
and then nothing will happen.
(chill music)
- So we can taste it?
- I feel like I taste the whole sea.
- I taste the whole sea.
- The whole, ooh, this
this got plastic in it.
- I would guess that
this is a scenario where,
the fish are in the ocean,
there's a f-ton of plastics in the ocean.
- There's no way it's not
gonna have microplastics.
- They're going to eat plastic.
- I'd believe that there
was microplastics in that.
- I'm gonna say no, just
because if you get it wrong
then I get it right.
So, let's just go for it.
- [Interviewer] You're
correct, there have been
trace amounts of plastic
discovered in fish.
- I'm not happy 'cause of that,
I'm happy 'cause I was
right and she was wrong.
- Like in the flesh,
in all testable parts?
Or like, in its bowels?
- [Interviewer] So, it's been discovered
in fish bowels and fish livers.
- People can't be mad that there's plastic
in their food, if you're
gonna put it in the water.
(futuristic music)
- Is this salt?
- I bet every other one of
these little ball things
is a piece of plastic.
- Yes, I think so.
'Cause salt comes from
the ocean too, right?
- A sea salt, or a kosher
salt might be different.
Does that matter?
Is it like part of the
machining process, or?
- I'm starting to think
that this is a trick,
and everything has microplastics in it.
- Me too.
- I'm gonna say yes.
- I mean, this just looks
like plastic, doesn't it.
- Oh my God, I'm gonna be wrong, so yes.
- I say no.
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] There has
been plastic found in salt.
- Ay.
- Why you twerking?
We're eating plastic.
- I don't eat a lot of salt.
So, I'm still good.
- [Interviewer] There's salt
hidden in a lot of things.
- I love apples, y'all.
- I can't wait for them
to ruin this for you.
- Some fruit is coated with wax, right?
Is there some plastic in that wax?
Some residual (bleeping).
- How do you know this?
- It's safe to assume that there's
a little bit of something everywhere.
- Everything has plastic in it,
and I'm not surprised if this has plastic.
- I'd say yeah.
- There are.
- I agree.
- I'd like to say no.
- Yeah.
- I'd like to say fruit is watered
with fresh water from the river.
Where there's also plastic, oh (bleeping).
- Just as a gambling person, I think
we've had two yeses in
a row, I'm gonna go no.
- You're right, like a test.
- [Interviewer] There have
not been trace amounts
of microplastics found in apples, yet.
- It feels good to eat
some plastic-free fruit.
- I mean, let's not get started on
the pesticides and stuff like that.
- Oh yeah.
Who knows what we just ate.
- (laughing) Right.
(guitar music)
- Cheers.
(clinking)
- Well, no beer comes in plastic
containers, we know that.
Right?
- I think no.
- I'm gonna say no, 'cause
I really wanna believe
there's no plastic in beer.
- I'm gonna say yes.
Something about like linings
in cans or something.
- No.
- I'm gonna go with yes.
- Um actually, read a article.
Y'all didn't know she's
cute, educated, and woke.
Actually can be some traces of plastic
in your favorite beer.
- Round of applause for Joyce, everyone.
So, I guess that's a yes?
- [Interviewer] Yes.
(laughing)
- See, she's educated, funny, and smart.
- I mean, the alcohol will kill you
before the microplastics does.
That's for sure.
- The alcohol should
kill the microplastic.
- You would hope so, but.
- Knowing there's plastic
in beer, do you care?
- I would have to understand which brands
are contaminated with it
because I have a feeling
that I'm already selectively
not drinking those.
Because I don't like cheap beer.
Sorry, bougie taste.
(orchestral music)
The stuff we do to cows is messed up.
There's almost certainly
some plastic in there.
- Though, what you're saying is true,
I want to say no.
- We're all doomed, it's probably yes.
- Wow, I haven't had real milk in a while.
- What is that, two percent?
I've always been confused
about the percents.
- It's the percent of plastic.
- I don't think so.
- I'm gonna say probably.
- [Interviewer] Yes, it's
been found in milk, too.
- How?
- It's always been a little weird
that we drink milk anyway, so.
(futuristic music)
- Ooh.
- This has microplastics in it.
- I wanna say, I have tasted
plastic in water before.
- There's nothing worse
than a weird tasting water.
You're like, ooh.
- Like, what is, like uh, how do plastics
even get in here, you know?
'Cause when I think of plastic,
I think of like plastic.
I don't think of liquids, I don't think of
something I can chew
and swallow effectively.
- I wanna say no, but at this point
I've been proven wrong multiple times.
So, yes.
- It's gotta be.
- Yeah, it's probably got...
- Is this spring water.
If it's spring water, I would say,
I've been wrong this whole time.
I'll just go yes.
- I think it's in the water.
- [Interviewer] Researchers
sourced tap water
from all around the globe,
and microplastics were discovered
in 81% of those samples.
- That's brutal.
- Well, there has to be
somewhere in the world
you can go where tap
water is okay to drink.
- I feel like, humans, we're so bad
that we're probably not gonna try to get
plastic out of our food.
We're just gonna try to like come up
with a way to make us immune to plastic.
Like a vaccine.
- Yeah.
- I mean, we treat the Earth like garbage.
- We'll start like making food on Mars,
where it's like 100% no plastic.
And then, we import
food from other planets.
That'll be like the
ultimate organic level.
It wasn't even made on Earth.
- I'll probably buy it.
- We can't even really tell what's natural
and what's not anymore.
- There's no way having plastic
in your body's good for you.
I'm sure over time too, there's
some serious ramifications.
- [Interviewer] If you're
worried about plastic,
something you can do is try to refuse
single-use plastics by
carrying reusables with you.